et voilà pour le troisième volet de
cette trilogie impressionnante sur les
noirs de france une trilogie signée juan
gallas à la réalisation et pascal
blanchard qui est avec nous comme
coauteurs alors bien sûr on va revenir
sur ce documentaire sur cette communauté
des noirs de france dont on comprend
toute la richesse toute la diversité
on va en parler alors que aux états unis
les américains se sont prononcés sur la
réélection d'obama et qu'en france est
bien allé question de racisme
l'islamophobie aussi intégrer nos
phobies reviennent temps en tête
d'affiche avec ce racisme anti blanc
avec le bloc identitaire avec des
gaulois menacés on va parler de tout ça
des noirs de france de la façon dont ils
sont perçus respectés en france quelques
fois discriminés sur la place donc ils
se sont fait qu'on leur a faites et
autour de moi pour en parler
rokhaya diallo vous êtes éditorialistes
et vous êtes fondatrice d'un mouvement
qui s'appelle des indivisibles et vous
avez écrit de livre qui s'appelle
racisme mode d'emploi chez larousse et
puis à nous la france chez laffont c'est
pas pour vous provoquer mais vous êtes
d'où vous de paris ivème arrondissement
mais à part ça nous faisait bon moment
on en parlera tout à l'heure georges
patient vous êtes sénateur socialiste en
double c'est plus compliqué en guyane
qu'ailleurs apparenté socialiste et
maire de mada mad alors vous me dites
c'est tout temps tout à fait au nord
ouest de la guyane peu face au surinam
gaston kelman êtes écrivain on se
souvient tous de je suis noir mais je
n'aime pas le manioc et 2 n'aime pas le
manioc et je n'aime pas mes yeux
j'ai dit quoi et je n'aime pas le manioc
d'accord et vous avez écrit aussi au
delà du noir et du blanc est écrit
parlons aux enfants de la patrie et puis
la bible de l'humour noir parce qu' un
humour noir ou en tout cas au brésil qui
bloquait effectivement une fois le
gardien niçois plus qu'ils soient olé
olé où on se raconte des histoires sur
nous mêmes on se tape dessus et on
laisse les autres parler de nous et puis
on parle de aussi etc ont vite je suis
noir et je n'aime pas le manioc c'est
une façon de dire je suis noir et alors
c'est pas ça lui c'est fini
ah oui alors mal passé à autre chose
parce qu'on ferait bon et pascal
blanchard vous avez fait cette trilogie
un très gros boulot et vous la sortez de
ce livre qui s'appelle la france thouars
trois siècles de présence
je sais le passage tous un bon bouquin
noël approche ou en profiter avec des
supers photo et un beau texte sur cette
grande histoire là que vous nous
racontez qui est vraiment lié à
l'histoire de france c'est une autre
histoire totalement notre histoire est
quelque part ne pas connaître l'histoire
des noirs de france et enlever un des
pans de notre récit comment on comprend
rien aux siècles xviie et xviiie se
comprend pas la place qu à l esclavage
on comprend rien au 19e siècle ne
comprend pas l'émergence d'élites noir
aussi bien au sein de l'armée française
que dans nos universités que en tant que
grand avocat haïtien par exemple qui à
paris se battent à la fin 19e pour
défendre des idées d'égalité et on ne
comprend rien au xxème siècle or là en
moins se comprend pas que pendant deux
conflits ces présences ont été
déterminantes si on ne comprend pas la
vie intellectuelle l'histoire de la
négritude sur ne comprend pas d'une
certaine manière que notre pays s'est
fait ensemble
et bien cette histoire l'a fait que nous
comprenons mieux notre histoire commune
soit pas été nous élever dans l'esprit
et le souvenir des colonies c'était de
l'histoire ancienne même que après les
années 60 on n'en parlait pas trop
d'ailleurs s'était renvoyé à plus tard
or cette histoire des colonies ce notre
histoire à nous elle nous accompagne on
a fait route avec l'afrique pendant des
années des années ses plus jeunes encore
plus complexe que ça c'est que d'une
certaine manière nous nous sommes
fabriqués à l'aune de cette histoire
coloniale et d'ailleurs nous sommes un
pays qui a encore sur quatre océans une
histoire notre présence ne s'est pas
arrêtée avec on pense que le temps des
colonies s'est arrêté à un moment qui ne
s'est rien passé ensuite
mais c'est beaucoup plus complexe
histoire nous avons vu certains empire
mais nous avons toujours des outre-mer
et d'ailleurs il ya souvent autant
d'ultramarins ici que là-bas on voit
bien que ce monde se mélange
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que de
penser que tout ça se couperaient
longtemps il n'y a jamais eu vraiment de
cesu
nous pensons que le temps des colonies
est loin et en même temps les gens me
grey venez en france alors que quelque
part l' empire colonial afrique n'était
pas terminée toutes ces histoires se
superposer nous fabriquent aujourd'hui
dans nos identités multiples tout ça
c'est ce que vous racontez ce sera très
bien dans ses trois volets ce grand
documentaire sur les noirs de france
c'est une idée qui vous est venu tout
seul ou c'est à une commande saas effet
comment de le choisir de faire un
documentaire travail pareil vous savez
comment ça se passe on a l'idée pendant
très longtemps puis un jour la
télévision vous dis oui je crois qu'il
ya 15 ans on en a parlé on nous a dit
non il ya dix ans nous a parlé nous a
dit non et en occident orient pour des
raisons très simples c'était oui ça fait
peut-être un peu trop communautariste et
l'autre moment c'est l'opinion n'est
peut-être pas prêt puis l'autre moment
c'était est ce qu'il ya vraiment une
histoire à raconter des noirs de france
et puis il ya un moment tous avancent
entre les réalisateurs et producteurs
des télévisions sont d'un seul coup en
face d'intérêt et puis aussi des témoins
qui avaient envie de raconter cette
histoire un film c'est aussi des gens
qui parlent rokhaya dans le film madame
taubira et dans le même désir
gaston est dans le film c'est aussi
l'histoire d'un moment de mettre des
gens qui ont tous des identités
différentes ont tous des parcours
différents camps tous des récits
différents justement qui vous raconter
qu'il n'y a pas une manière d'être
devant la crise surpris le plus dans ces
parcours différents et ses perceptions
différentes parce que entre vous deux
par exemple rokhaya et gaston et a pas
tout à fait la même approche
heureusement si j'avais la même
génération et c'est aussi peut-être de
regards santé mais c'est pas de regards
vont à 35 témoins dans ses films ses 35
regard différent des lacets la première
surprise des gens qui ont regardé les
films c'est qu'il n'y a pas une manière
de raconter l'histoire d'une heure de
france ou d'être noir de france c'est
pour ça que la chambre communauté est un
vaste débat c'est cannes a pas un qui
pense pareil cette histoire de cette
communauté nous pensons que c'est une
communauté et je pense que il nous
raconte une autre histoire celle là
c'est leur histoire individuelle qui
boutabout fabrique une histoire connue
dans la communauté on va parler
justement cette communauté et l homogène
ou pas est elle cohérente ou pas sur des
absents parce qu il ya des présents et
les absents j'ai pas vu noah tribunaux
en à l'image mais je n'ai pas entendu le
documentaire j'aurais été viré de
l'entente on n'a pas à rama yade qui
dieu c'est rama yade s'est elle aussi
elle n'est pas dans le film c'est
canadien elle a refusé
alors c'est très drôle parce qu'elle a
refusé à ce moment là n'était alors faut
rappeler du contexte politique de rama
qui était aux mains du gouvernement
juste avant de ne plus être au goût
moment et elle m'a dit à l'époque je ne
veux pas être vu que comme une femme
politique noir
je dis oui c'est marrant parce que
quelque part vous avez créé un livre qui
se porte le nom de ce film noir de
france donc c'est très ambigu ya un
moment dans sa carrière politique ça
l'arrangeait d'être une femme noire
jeune femme noire et à un moment ça ne
l'arrangé plus à l'ump d'être une jeune
femme noire en même temps sa non
présence dans le film fait partie de
l'histoire du film aujourd'hui et
c'était un long débat un je dirais que
de votre vie vous avez parlé longuement
je pense que je vais voir encore et les
quarante sms échangés le ski discussions
et sms et quand vous vous battez pour
que des gens viennent dans un film il
faut argumenter moi je vous souhaite
commencer avec harlem désir c'est
extrêmement intéressant
harlem n'avait jamais raconter cette
histoire car les mains on m'a dit j'ai
pas c'est compliqué comme on le raconte
sg au bout de cinq mois de conversation
avec un gain immédiat ok ok je la
raconte mais il a fallu cinq mois pour
que harlem désir à la cep de devenir une
star histoire à lui oui parce que pas
sur l'histoire à lui de son histoire à
lui dans un film qui s'appelle hors de
france et qui racontait le récit
peut-être avec un an qui était pas
forcément aussi au départ il est donc on
a discuté avec lui comme comme avec
certains certains m'ont dit de cours en
parle comme on en parle pourquoi on en
parle
quelle histoire on va raconter ensemble
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé aux
guerres j'ai trouvé ça très intéressant
effectivement sur la question de la
communauté noire c'est une construction
de perception plus qu'une réalité
objective
quand vous disiez que entre gaston
kelman y avait une différence évidente
effectivement n'appartenant pas la même
génération moi je suis né ici vous avez
connu un parcours migratoire je suis
aussi une femme le fait d'être une femme
noire s'est encore passé pas la même
chose que le fait d'être un homme noir
on a une perspective complètement
différente et les témoignages montrent
justement la complexité de cette figure
noire qu'on aime réduira son essence et
on se pose c'est à dire que il ya un
livre qui s'appelle on ne naît pas noir
on le devient moi je suis né en france
et j'ai découvert que j'étais noir
lorsque j'étais petit parce qu'on me l'a
fait remarquer mais quand on est un
petit enfant français on ne se pensent
ni blanc ni noir c'est le regard
extérieur qui nous construit comme cela
et qui fait que finalement on va soit le
revendiquer soient contestées le statut
qui nous est associée du fait de notre
couleur blanc banquise et moi mais vous
voyez vos parents vous voyez des parents
les ont faits
- j'ai une amie qui enseigne en école
maternelle un jour un petit garçon est
venu la voir en lisant son camarade
l'embêter elle lui demande quelques
camarades tambay t elle dit c'est le
noir alors on cherche à cacher j'avais
un peu embêté et c est en fait ils
trouvent que le noir en question était
un petit enfant blanc qui avait une
veste noire
les enfants ne perçoivent pas les
couleurs de peau de la même manière que
nous je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui est à priori là on a vraiment une
différence à la couleur de peau moi j'ai
grandi dans un environnement dans le
nord de paris dans son environnement où
j'étais dans un immeuble où la majorité
des gens étaient issus de la commune
étaient d'origine asiatique était venu
en fait des communautés qui étaient
venus avec les boat people
je me suis jamais posé la question de
l'être différence ce sont les adultes
qui ne faisant qu il faut remarquer en
fait qu'on a une couleur de peau
différente qu'à sagot duvauroux dit on
ne naît pas noir l'été vient c'est
vraiment ça la vérité on peut vous
raconter mille anecdotes ont
effectivement les enfants à découvrir
qu'ils sont noirs parce qu'on leur a dit
où les enfants blancs ne savent pas que
leurs âmes étaient noirs que leurs
camarades de classe était noir jusqu'au
jour où
mais tu n'as pas dit que tu as camarades
étaient noirs et la p'tite blan che
surprise qu'on considère sa camarade son
amie de classe qu'on est noir
effectivement lacombe repère le dit en
riant devient noir et à partir de là
c'est le choix qu'ont fait après et
c'est parfois là que ça change moi je
considère que à la naissance du
mouvement pendant la négritude c'était
presque incontournable que de se fonder
sur cette espèce de de cataplasme
d'ectoplasmes qu'on avait construit
parce que le problème du noir c'est que
c'est pas lui qui définit comme noir le
problème de noir c'est que c'est
quelqu'un de petits décide un jour qu'il
est noir avec tout ce que cela porte
derrière deux avec peut-être une nuance
apportée aujourd'hui où il ya des gens
qui revendiquent mais de qualité noir de
la naissance de la race noire
on va dire que c'est pas le noir qui au
congo au cameroun dit nous on est les
noirs ils sont congolais mentaux et puis
comme on est tout ce qu'on veut mais un
jour on est venu le noir dans une
stratification raciale où il ya le blanc
le jaune le rouge et le noir et lac
quand le noir découvre les noirs soit
avec la négritude et se foncent dessus
pour dire ok on est noir mais en
revendique ceci dit cela on est noir
mais on a une culture une civilisation
mais quand on évolue on arrête déjà
frantz fanon qu'on a dont on a parlé
dans le documentaire qui dit je suis pas
non
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
de peuple noir de nationaux ça n'existe
pas on rencontre des tyroliens aussi
tiens était un écrivain martiniquais
qui dit lenoir n'existe pas pourquoi ma
ferme et rêche dans cette image de moi
qu'ils voudraient pétrifiée et puis on
arrive aujourd'hui à ce siècle
effectivement beaucoup de jeunes et
beaucoup de personnes se fonde justement
sur cet a priori pour le détruire
mais moi je pars déjà au départ pour
dire je ne veux pas rentrer dans cette
définition
dans cette fiction en noir et blanc de
l'homme dans cette espèce de négatif
d'une autre parce que c'est comme ça que
ce supplice aux sénateurs cette
communauté on va essayer d'en parler
mais on parle de quelques munauté et on
va écouter harlem désir justement sur la
présence des antilles et dans cette
communauté noire et dans ce film et
c'est avec et dans les souhaits ce
racisme ou au départ les antilles disent
nous on a un vaccin nous on est pas on
n'est pas des noirs d'afrique entre
guillemets donc c'est intéressant et
vous me direz un petit peu de quelle
communauté au parc quand on parle de la
communauté noire
il n'y avait pas énormément d'antillais
mobilisés au début un sos au fond j'ai
l'impression je vois ça des antillais
que je connais et que je connaissais à
l'époque qu'il ya eu un peu probablement
de sentiments mais au fond nous on n'est
pas concerné il ya aujourd'hui une peur
de l'immigration
il faut qu'on fasse attention apple est
assimilé à l'immigration
alors est-ce que ça a été dirais presque
un risque pour vous qui êtes de guyane
est ce que vous êtes dit attendez nous
on est français on est un département
français on n'a rien à voir avec les
noirs qui viennent par exemple je parle
du mali ou d'ailleurs et qui sont venus
soit au titre 50 10 soit tout simplement
en immigration de travail en france je
pense qu'à un moment de l'histoire
et effectivement les antilles et la
guyane et les réunionnais j'ai senti un
peu à part en disant qu'ils étaient
certainement droit mais qu'ils étaient
avant tout français et par la suite
il faut le constater les noirs tous les
noirs de france se sent tous sentis
pareil subissant les mêmes
discriminations en termes d'emploi et de
logement
et on arrive actuellement à faire partie
de cette communauté si je peux employer
ce terme ces deux communautés de noirs
de france
je voudrais profiter pour dire que
justement le petit reproche que je peux
faire
au fait office documentaire c'est le
fait que l'on ne traite pas suffisamment
des noirs de france qui sommes dans les
autres mers est là c'est aussi les
entend beaucoup il il parle mais en
france ils font partie d'une communauté
métropolitaine on parle pas des antilles
en antenne mais par le ter pain pour le
terme france même si l' empire s'est
disloqué mais il reste quand même et
outre-mer vous en parlais tout à l'heure
il existe des noirs aussi dans les
territoires d'outre-mer qui subissent
toujours les mêmes la france aussi c'est
la france aussi et qui subissent
toujours les mêmes discriminations et
peut-être même pire ça je tiens
également à le dire parce que ici la
majorité et blanche
les noirs sont minoritaires mais chez
nous on a des autres maires très voir
les noirs sont majoritaires et pourtant
toute l'administration est contrôlé par
toujours 10% doublant c'était un peu
l'idée du documentaire c'était de se
poser comme si on avait posé notre
caméra d'ici où justement
s'entrecroisent des histoires c'est à
dire que ce qui était intéressant
c'était par exemple on allait faire un
film sur l'histoire d'un esclavage aux
antilles mais de regarder comment était
vu des esclaves ya deux trois siècles
ici en métropole de regarder aussi
comment les flux migratoires parce que
on a beau dire c'est passablement
traversée d'un département à l'autre
quand vous de guyane vous venez en
métropole au camp des antilles ou nord
métropole d'avoir ce long voyage que
l'état organisé sa pleine luminosité
histoire très particulière qui est pas
la même histoire que ceux qui sont
restés une époque où on à organiser
l'immigration massive à 2d en version 3
jusqu'à 80 jusqu'en france parce qu'on
avait besoin de cette manoeuvre là et
qu'on voulait pas de troubles d'ailleurs
aussi aux antilles il a été un choix
politique de privilégier ses populations
et leur flux migratoires vers la france
plutôt que d'autres populations de cette
histoire est racontée aussi d'ici parce
que
le documentaire avait été fait sur la
guyane la guadeloupe la martinique et
nous on la veut dire on va des centres
et le regard justement pour raconter
l'histoire d'entrecroisement d'autres
population y est ce que ça veut dire que
vous mettez sur le même plan de
migration si je puis dire des noirs qui
arrivent des ordi ou des noirs qui
arrive du mali le congo ne les met pas
sur le même plan mais par contre je dis
que le récit migratoires à quelque chose
de commun dans son sous quand vous
partez de chez vous c'est un
déracinement quand vous allez vers un
ailleurs vous installer dans une société
où on vous regarde autrement
lilian thuram d'une phrase dans le film
qui résume je pense que de 0,15 à tout à
l'heure je suis devenu noir à l'âge de 8
ans quand on arrive en france en
arrivant ce qu'ils disent et c'est ça
qui m'intéresse c'est moi dans
l'histoire c'est à dire que cette
histoire elle n'avait pas en guadeloupe
colisée tranquillement dans son village
personnalisé est le petit noir du mali
cruel et six personnes parler comme ça
et quand il a débarqué dans sa banlieue
comme il dit d'un seul coup ligi compris
que j'étais noir le clavier nouvelle
histoire qui s'écrit une histoire du
regard et c'est aussi celle là pour vous
les raconter et là c'est pas la même
produire dans un pays majoritaires
rokhaya diallo noirs de france loi en
france
non c'était français noirs de france
marc en france il ya plusieurs défis
liés via rend les différences d'approché
parce qu'effectivement on parle de gens
qui arrivent et aussi des gens qui ne
sont jamais arrivés parce qu'ils ont
toujours été là il ya aussi cette
question de perception moi c'est vrai
que la question de l'antiracisme et de
la fondation des indivisibles que j'ai
fondé maintenant il ya il ya un peu plus
de cinq ans l ailier vraiment cette
perception c'est à dire que moi je me
suis toujours pensé comme étant comme
les camarades
quelle que soit leur couleur de peau une
française a par la suite par les yeux
j'ai vécu en banlieue rouge peut être
court 9e 6 si vous voulez vraiment des
détails j'ai convenu renvoie
systématiquement à vos parents louis qui
sont je sais plus quel granby et ses
dégâts je crois voir absolument
ça vous énerve ça m'énerve c'est que je
me rends compte que mes camarades dont
les parents sont espagnol italien
polonais etc ne sont pas renvoyés la
même s'il s'est passé avec quinze jours
on dit tiens tu viens d'où tu viens
dehors bourgogne de chez parle beaucoup
de moi je suis pas gêné par par mes
origines mais simplement je ne veux pas
qu'on me raconte qu'on existe qu'on
exige de moi que je raconte une histoire
qui n'est pas la mienne je connais
beaucoup
moi je suis né en france moi si on veut
faire parler une tête du sénégal pendant
les heures g
moment j'attends des limites qui sont
celles mais bon faut pas que j'aie autre
histoire
absolument et paris sont en france
depuis mon père est arrivé quand même il
ya plus de quarante ans il a depuis très
longtemps et ma mère est arrivée il ya
35 ans donc à la passe et plus longtemps
en france aujourd'hui que au sénégal et
en afrique
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
que la couleur de peau aussi donnent
enfin fait ou que les gens présuppose de
vous que vous avez une certaine culture
parfois certains goûts maintenant il ya
des gens qui imaginent parfois experte
en hip hop ou en basket alors que c'est
parce que je ne suis pas élu il m'est
déjà arrivé si vous voulez parler enfin
moi je couvre les anecdotes sont
toujours très très parlant mais j'ai
souvenir lorsque je travaillais dans une
dans une société où on faisait des repas
pour les la fin de l'année et c'est tout
le monde devait apporter un repas de
chez soi c'est un peu le moment car vous
allez maintenant est ce que tu peux
renier en plaques chez toi et j'ai
fortement hésité à porter un kebab dans
le nord de paris mais cette façon de 2,2
voilà de d'imaginer que chez moi
forcément on cuisine des plats exotiques
très très lointain alors voir de france
part en france vous vous revendiquez
votre appartenance aux origines qu'un
monet c'est ça ben oui cameroun est
justement mêmes bas ça pourrait la
profondeur banc tout ce qu'on veut sauf
noir moi je dis que je voudrais c'est
d'être noir je voudrais donc tout
simplement il faudra qu'un jour la
négritude ne soit plus un critère des
définitions de l'individu passe
aujourd'hui comme nous tous nous sommes
d'accord sur un point ici on est d'abord
noir avant d'être autre chose hélas
alors que je souhaite être autre chose
je vous assure que moi je suis devenu
noir quand ce dernier en france c'est là
qu'on m'a dit les noirs font comme ceci
au cameroun on me disait les camerounais
sont comme si c'est les bassins sont
comme cela mais je n'avais jamais
affronté les noirs avaient une ligne
directrice parce qu'il y avait un
musulman je ne prêtais de musulmans xi e
communauté noire elle s'agrègent dans
l'adversité contre les blancs wade de
cette façon nous mais on a des vertus à
cette fiction pour moi vraiment la
communauté noire est une fiction
nous avons vu la multiplicité
c'est-à-dire est le fondement est faux
il est fictif définir des gens comme des
noirs le bambara qui exactement comme le
type de matha by leoni aussi que
l'europe heures devant la mairie à une
communauté noire ou des services
et nous voulons en sortir moi
personnellement je ne demande qu'à
sortir de 17 livres et ce fan on
l'appelle à livrer la livre et qu'on m'a
mise qui seraient porteuses de d'activer
bien spécifique et puis de qualités et
des défauts bien spécifiques
georges patient c'est quoi le point que
le point commun entre quelqu'un qui a
aidé en tire encore une fois quelqu'un
qui est venu parler économique ils
devenus fous qu'être français
et puis quelqu'un qui est venu par
l'immigration pour travailler et qui a
été naturalisé est ce qu'il ya des pour
beaucoup même qui était encore
travailleurs ou quelqu'un qui travaille
aujourd'hui qui travailleurs immigrés
mais qui n'est pas français ce que tous
ces gens là parce qu'ils sont noirs ou
ont quelque chose en commun
il ya une réalité quand même des noirs
en france et peut-être pas une
communauté noire
mais une réalité des noirs en france qui
ont les mêmes problèmes il faut être
concret il faut que ça roule un problème
qui l'épaulait un problème matériel
emploi le logement les difficultés
qu'ont les noirs de pro à trouver il a
trouvé un logement d'emploi travailleurs
immigrés qui a laissé des milliers qui a
fait des études série les noirs on a
très souvent on en fait référence quand
il s'agit de grands écrivains
de grands intellectuels de grands
sportifs de grands artistes mais il
faudrait effectivement qu'on parle
également du noir normal puisqu'il faut
employer ce terme est très à la mode le
noir normal le noir normal comment est
il perçu en france
bon dans votre ouvrage c'est très bien
bon c'est vrai qu'on va d'autres grandes
figures noires
c'est là mon problème à la réanimer mais
voulait lui même les stars des enfants
même les grandes stars de photos de
football maintenant elle se met à accès
exprimer leur sentiment sur le racisme
anti-noir bon mais ça c'est tout récent
mais il ya une population de couleur
noire qui vit depuis très longtemps en
france et qui subit l'ostracisme le
racisme la population immigrée blanche
venant des pays de l'est a pu se fondre
dans la communauté dans la société
française
alors que les gens se font alors des
noirs pour l'instant les noirs c'est la
façon dont sont perçus c'est qu'ils sont
perçus est considéré comme comme noir
donc à une question de perception de
traitement de discrimination qui unit de
fait les noirs et qui peut faire aussi
que des gens vont s'organiser s'unir
pour lutter contre une perception qui
n'est pas la leur on ne se lève pas tous
les matins posé dimanche à ce film et
quand vous par rapport à ce qu'on est
alors quand vous croisez quelqu'un vous
connaissez pas qu'il marque vous et vous
lui tu tu viens d'où il ya des gens que
je connais je ne sais même pas quelle
région ils sont parce que enfin on
apprécie peut-être personnel mais ça
m'intéresse pas toujours et je ne sais
pas quelque chose qui me saute aux yeux
j'ai des amis qui sont d'origine assez
diverses moi j'ai envie de prendre un
environnement extrêmement mélanger ma
nounou était d'origine laotienne etc
mais c'est pas quelque chose qui peut
qui pose des questions parce qu'on était
tous d'origines étrangères il s'agit
d'un point par rapport à cette couleur
de peau et ses questionnements qui suit
si vous parlez de racine
j'aimerais qu'on réécoute ce conte cette
phrase jacques chirac on entend dans
votre documentaire et canton l'arrêt en
temps on se dit mais qu'est ce soir 1991
il est président du rpr et voilà ce qui
dit sur ces communautés noires
par ailleurs france et qui travaille
avec sa part et qui ensemble gagne
environ 15000 francs et qu'ils voient
sur le palier à côté de son hlm entassée
une famille avec un père de famille
trois ou quatre épouses et une vingtaine
de gosses et qui gagnent 50 mille francs
de prestations sociales sans
naturellement travailler
si vous ajoutez à cela remet
si vous ajoutez à cela le bruit et
l'odeur est bien le travailleur français
sur le palier deviens fou et devient fou
c'est comme ça alors ça c'est bon c'est
une chose de le dire c'est une chose de
l'entendre c'est vrai
après derrière deux fois particulier et
c'est une chance de leur dire
aujourd'hui un beaucoup de gens qui ont
complètement oublié que ce que nous
vivons des fois aujourd'hui s'inscrit
dans l'histoire
oui les conversations que nous avons là
et ici on est tous suffisamment loin de
le comprendre
c'est aussi un rapport à l'histoire de
ce qui s'est passé avant le combat par
exemple pour l'abolition des esclavages
en guyane et aux antilles l'histoire
coloniale
l'histoire aussi la négritude un moment
aussi des noirs se sont rassemblés au
congrès la race noire à paris c'est pas
moi qui la montrent la force noire pour
ma guerre il ya des moments de
l'histoire quand forger des combats
communs et quelque part de revenir à ce
regard qui est posée quand il dit le
français il en a ras-le-bol sarkozy veut
dire déjà que le noir ne peut pas être
français et l'imaginaire d'un homme
politique qui va devenir présent la
république de qualifier que quelqu'un
sur un pas de porc il ya déjà et
maintenant il explique que quelque part
et dans la tête de beaucoup de gamins
aujourd'hui qui sont perdus dans leur
identité
quand ils entendent ça et qu'ils l'ont
entendu pendant toute leur vie qu'être
noir c'est déjà pas être vraiment
français c'est presque un français au
trou un français d outre-mer ou
d'afrique
c'est compliqué de se construire c'est
pour ça que quand vous dites alors qu à
quoi ça sert aussi par les actes de ces
questions là c'est aussi d'arriver à
essayer d'arriver à replacer ce présent
dans la complexe parce que c'est
complexe comment garder calme à 13 c sur
non mais ce racisme là on l'entend l'an
91 est ce qu'aujourd'hui je vous disais
tout à l'heure il ya du
des choses qui remonte en ce moment ils
soient du pain au chocolat il ya le
racisme le petit le racisme anti blanc
ces choses là ça remonte sera si vous
allez relation qui revient encore plus
fort s'ils avaient un peu eu tendance à
disparaître ou j'ai pas vraiment
l'impression qu'il ya eu des évolutions
je veux dire caractéristiques mais c'est
plutôt une bonne impression c'est que la
communauté entre guillemets noir qui
n'en est pas une et en train de prouver
qu'il est dit m une classe moyenne qui
est capable de s'occuper d'elle-même et
ce qui fait que les gens peuvent penser
des choses qu'en ce moment c'est pas ça
qui me gêne les gens peuvent penser tout
ce qu'il veut mais à partir du moment où
vous imposer par la capacité à faire des
choses il est clair qu'il ya 20 ans 15
ans nous ne serions pas sur ce plateau
au près et moi peut-être même pas le
sénateur ce serait un footballeur et
puis non c'est ça il faudra leur est un
rappeur parce que l'image noir c'était
que celle là aujourd'hui la société
française reconnaît qu'il ya et c'est
souvent là que chirac disent par exemple
ceux ci qu'est ce que j'aurais répondent
à celles âgées de surprenant de véraison
je vous assure que si j'ai cette famille
donc là moi ça va mais je n'ai testé ce
qui est content des eaux de
ruissellement et c'est comme ça que je
lui dis lui que nous ne baissent quand
je lui dis que votre famille l'année
fictive vous raconter des choses vont
plaire aux gens et moi ce que je dis
parfois au noir ce matin jeudi sperme
avoir une
j'ai regardé un reportage c'était un
noir entre guillemets qui est je crois
le 80plus invente grand inventeur au
monde aujourd'hui
il accueillait un robot d'une puissance
absolue ce type ce il se met sur la
place du sénat
on va lui demander ce que le vigile du
coin et qu'est ce que le gars va faire
il va des bruits je suis vigilant parce
que moi je dis je suis à ce que je dis
je suis bourguignon on dit maintenant tu
acceptes pas je ne vois pas musclé
pourquoi maintenant faire mirage dans
cette image de moi qui voudraient
pétrifiée je voulais que le mois et
samoa d'esprit que je suis le quatrième
plus un bar grand inventeur du monde
aujourd'hui mais regardez par exemple le
nombre de médecins
je voudrais une seule statistique
aujourd'hui pascal toi tu peux t'en
occuper camp nou entre les lignes le
nombre de médecins noir qui avait ya 20
ans et donc combien là aujourd'hui
moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse voir qu'il
ya une place moins car paraît donc vous
les gens ça bouge du côté des doigts ils
sont là professeur est bon ça il est là
une asbl et rokhaya 150 âmes et louis
mentalité burbach leader de racisme est
ce que dans les mentalités des blancs ça
bouge je me dis il ya deux positions
assez semblable en fait entre la
population et les gouvernants de toutes
les façons pour les deux on pourrait
considérer que la perception est la même
mais la population elle a toujours pas
c'est toujours pas libéré de ses
préjugés raciaux et les gouvernants sont
un petit peu embarrassé par sa
formulation n'a pas évolué dit très peu
très peu ça sera tout à fait encore bien
libérer de cette génération
il y avait sur jamais lors qu'il est bon
en 30 parties d'ailleurs on voit bien
comme comment joue là dessus le front
national et même coupé toute la clique
il ya encore des préjugés raciaux qui
existe et c'est pas la france et là oui
voilà c'est pas la france dans les cours
de récré dans les rues le relais oui les
politiques qui jouent sur et les médias
les aliments et puis les gouvernants qui
sont un petit peu embarrassée parce que
finalement les noirs de france où les
lois en france sans la création des
gouvernants ce sont eux qui sont allés
chercher en afrique quand il en avait
besoin
qui les ont amenés dans les outre-mers
quand il en avait besoin qui les ont
ramenés encore en france quand il en
avait besoin
donc ils sont embarrassés par cette
situation voudrait bien faire avancer
les choses mais son coin c'est aussi eux
mêmes eux aussi avec leur rôle en
assists bon si les choses progressent
actuellement c'est parce que justement
bon les elite joue le rôle d'avant-garde
ça ce domaine au gaz le terrain des
temps et plus sains et plus optimiste
que vous avez une balle de l'émergence
glace moyenne en faire changer jolie
allez bye en noir
un vieux noir qui manifestent aussi donc
actuellement il faut prendre tout ça en
considération ces thèmes sont
effectivement il ya eu sans doute une
classe moyenne dans une classe
supérieure qui émergent mais elle a
rappelé qu'on est dans un pays où les
révoltes ont éclaté à clichy-sous-bois
en 2005 suite à la mort de deux
adolescents dont dont un était d'origine
maghrébine l'autre était noir donc on
est quand même dans un pays
moi je travaille beaucoup avec un
collectif qui s'appelle stop le contrôle
au faciès sur le contrôle au faciès
aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait c'est que
statistiquement lorsqu on et doit on a
six fois plus de chances d'être contrôlé
par un politique quand on est blanc
quand on est arabe huit fois plus le cas
quand même cette réalité là qu'est une
réalité qui conquit c'est à dire que
même si on est un noir deux classes
moyennes très très bien habillé dans une
voiture tout à fait voilà enfin comment
dire bourgeoise
on peut se retrouver confronté à un
contrôle policier et ça c'est
complètement indépendant de
l'appartenance réelle à une catégorie
sociale donc je compte leur assise bien
vous le ressentez comme ça moi je le
ressens moi parce que bon il se trouve
que ces genres et c est là le contrôle
au faciès se faisait s'exécute en
partant 90% sur des hommes dont je n'ai
jamais été contrôlé au faciès mais je ne
ressens je veux dire je travaille pour
pour une radio qui s'appelle rtl les
premières fois que j'y suis et je me
suis rendu le vigile m'a arrêté en me
demandant où je me rendais donc on
allait à l'eau mais quand même c'est
quand même c'était la première radio de
france
donc on en est
on alerte auto les jeunes noirs bon je
reçois beaucoup et qui ont des bac + 3 +
4 qui cherchent un petit stage affaire
qui arrive pas à trouver parce qu'ils
sont noirs parce qu'ils sont non on est
sur quelque chose qui est très compliqué
enfin qui peut paraître compliqué à
comprendre et qui se comprend en deux
mots simples se sentir légitime dans un
pays c'est un double rapport c'est
soi-même déjà être fier de ce pays en se
disant qu'on est dans cette histoire
rappelez vous un moment ce qui s'est
passé quand il le film indigènes parle
de rachid bouchareb où des familles
entières maghrébins allez voir ce film
parce qu'il se fabriquer un grand père
potentiel de légitimité sur le
territoire et de l'autre côté nous
devons expliquer à tous les français que
cette histoire en commun et fait la
france
alors ça vous paraît bizarre ce que je
viens de dire mais c'est quelque chose
de très compliqué et oui il reste dans
les inconscients collectifs par exemple
regarder vraiment l'histoire l'équipe de
france de football des gens qui pensent
que si il y à un jour trop de noirs et
d'arabes dans l'équipe de france ait pu
l'équipe de france parce que leur modèle
leur manière de regarder le monde
histoire qu'ils ont appris à l'école ce
que l'athée leur a montré qu'ils sont
pas habitués à voir des médecins avoir
des élites avoir simplement qu'un
français peut être noir et pourtant ça
fait quatre siècles notre histoire
commune maghrébins asiatique d'origine
autres c'est très compliqué parce que ça
veut dire c'est tout un process on va
déconstruire des imaginaires et en même
temps va raconter une histoire commune
ou savez j'étais l'autre jour avec des
hommes politiques et des femmes
politiques et je leur expliquais que en
1904 un antillais et vice-président
l'assemblée nationale ils m'ont regardé
avec des yeux de merlan frit
il pensait que je racontais un jack que
c'était de l'humour donc j'ai dû leur
dire deux fois speroni durée l'histoire
de france l'assemblée nationale était
peut-être plus ouverte
un moment de son histoire qu'aujourd'hui
au métissage vous rendez compte un
président du sénat je vous fait d'être
un homme noir c'est un petit peu ce qui
est surprenant dans le documentaire
c'est vrai je dois le confesser aussi
c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'ils
avaient moins de préjugés vis-à-vis des
noirs qui était député sénateur enfin
ces terrains ministre en beaucoup plus
grands noms qu'aujourd'hui sous la
troisième ou quatrième république
je pense aussi à comment s'appelle-t-il
de ski à qui a écrit de la constitution
de 58 qui a coécrit la voix sur 58 ans
passés il y avait tout ça et aujourd'hui
on est on est ébahi quand on a un noir
qui devient ministre fasse ça devient
est-ce qu'on a régressé
ça veut dire une fiction qui s'est posée
je pense pas que
mentalement on a régressé évidemment
quand un éboueur manière venait on
n'allait pas faire un médecin on l'a
cherché d'éboueurs comme le type du beau
me demander à chercher subalterne
mais plus le temps passe plus les choses
évoluent et je vous assure que aussi
paradoxal que cela puisse paraître la
france est le pays où l'intégration se
fait le mieux pas du fait des élites
mais du fait des peuples je veux dire
que le maghrébin qui se plaint dans son
coin il est plus franchouillard que
jamais dans le petit noir qui se
plantent les plus franchouillard que
jamais imaginé le par ailleurs parce que
vous avez un mauvais caractère des
français dessous la défense au niveau en
dix ans il peut s'agir alors justement
elle l'a au moins ça me gêne c'est que
le cursus pour nous on aurait envie de
parfaire sa conduite est justement la
france est l'un des pays où on peut
vivre où on veut quand on a les moyens
de vivre c'est pas le cas aux états unis
où il ya des quartiers de blob en
angleterre les deux quartiers noirs cat
est riche de noir des quartiers riches
de blanc ont effectivement maintenant on
est toujours je vous dis le mariage
mixte en france il se trouve plus que
partout ailleurs c'est quand même aussi
d'indicateurs et c'est pour cela que je
vais vous n'avez pas l'impression qui a
reconnu notamment pour qu'on montre ce
qui marche et pas ce qui ne marche pas
je n'ai pas la patience aujourd'hui le
sakura rérat communautarisme juste de on
va pas dire un communautarisme pas du
tout on va vers des luttes qui sont tout
à fait légitimes ou les enfants de loin
parce qu'ils sont stigmatisés comme des
noirs 10 nous voulons sortir de cela
nous voulons sortir de cette vision qui
est de nous comme des noix
alors comment en sortir on va écouter la
dalle extrait de votre documentaire
c'est luc saint-eloy c'est ça qui
intervient à la cérémonie des césar on
les préfère imaginer dans ce pays une
télévision qui vous transmettrai
exclusivement des images de noir
imaginez dans ce pays des écrans
publicitaires à la télévision au cinéma
sur les murs de toutes les grandes
villes qui vanterait des produits de
consommation par des noirs pour manger
pour moi pour se laver pour se distraire
pour se vêtir pour dormir pour éduquer
nos enfants bref pour vivre et vous
chers compatriotes
imaginez que vous soyez absents
invisible imaginez seulement
mais rassurez vous
ce rôle d'absence c'est nous qui
l'interprétons mais ce n'est pas une
fiction
seulement notre dure réalité dans un
monde de blancs qui exclut toute une
partie de la population dont le seul
tort est d'être noir ou jaune alors veut
dire que je suis optimiste mais j'ai
l'impression que depuis cette époque je
me dis que les choses changent peut-être
vais vous merci au cinéma vous j'ai vu
ma société m'a fait qu harry roselmack
au batteur j'ai vu audrey pulvar ou la
critique aujourd'hui pas parce qu'elle
noah ont la critique parce que c'est la
femme de montebourg d'envoyer les choses
changent quand même nom et je changeais
en même temps dès mai 68 à la télévision
est une émission qui s'appelait
pulsations qui était sur les cultures
noires envoyer ton quand même temps on
peut avoir à la télévision une émission
spéciale sur les cultures noires
musicale et en même temps que la société
peut avoir des blocages
oui ça a changé il serait faux de dire
qu'il n'ya pas eu des évolutions que
heureusement que des hommes et des
femmes se sont battus comme la sq il a
fallu aller sur scène violente et
l'image faire ce discours brillant avoir
un grand acteur cette loi qui dit ces
choses essentielles à ce que tout le
monde se dit oui c'est vrai sur l'été
absent de partout en serait on aurait du
mal il faut encore que vous rendez
compte que dix ans après ça il faut
encore essayer d'expliquer dans les
rédactions dans les télévisions que ces
histoires ne devrait même plus faire
histoire qu'on devrait seul - dans une
norme que ce pays est métissé on parle
pas de communautarisme alors dit ce pays
à différentes cultures différents
territoires et cette série de rester
culture doivent simplement être
normalement dans nos médias blancs ni
plus ni moins et normalement continuer
encore à donner un petit coup de pouce
comme le demande le cran et pour
favoriser justement la représentation de
noirs dans les médias ou dans d'autres
professions est ce que c'est ça que
qu'il faut faire évidemment c'est à dire
que effectivement il y avait ce à
dessein des mesneux trajet qui ont été
vos reviennent tout cas je pense qu'il
faut y penser c'est à dire que on peut
pas se contenter de audrey pulvar de
harry roselmack qui d'ailleurs ne
présente plus 20 heures je tiens ce soir
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'a aucune
personne
noires qui présentent un journal majeur
à la télévision française donc on est
quand même plus extrêmes il peut en plus
ne plus faire le 20h de peur de son
propre os que ce que je veux dire c'est
que ce n'est pas un changement profond
c'est un changement qui a été un
changement affichée moi j'ai un souvenir
très précis de l'époque où harry
roselmack devait présenter faire un
remplacement d'ailleurs pour le 20
heures on nous l'a annoncé six mois
avant attention un noir va arriver dans
vos télévisions c'est pas un problème de
couleur dans les médias ça brouille fait
on s'en tenait alors qu'au même moment
en angleterre son homologue qui était
aussi noir prenait sa retraite donc on
voit bien quand même qu'il y avait un
décalage en termes d'époque des
minorités alors c'est pourquoi je pense
que moi je je je demande à ce qu'on
regarde par exemple les rédactions les
rédactions de la presse écrite notamment
où on voit bien que finalement la télé
est un devoir d'exigence et de
commentaires de représentation qu'ils
obligent mais les vérités ça ça lui
allait si mal ça regarde la presse
écrite je pense y compris la presse de
gauche qui est très très favorable aux
idées anti raciste on se rend bien
compte que le détour de table de
rédaction sont quand même plutôt
monocolore et ça c'est aussi c'est
valable aussi bien pour les gens de
couleur noire que pour les gens
d'origine maghrébine ou à la nation
positif faut y aller faut continuer pour
le faire chacun mène son combat c'est
pas le miel une aisée parce que j'ai
parfois la désagréable impression que
chaque fois qu'on commence à parler d'un
système c'est parce que les dépasser et
c'est ça qu'on fait très peur quand par
exemple vraiment paix à son âme quand de
quoi parle pas bien à porto les
dispositifs le patron de sciences po
lille qu'un cadre est sympa mais il ya
plein de gamins noirs et le risque c'est
qu'aujourd'hui chaque domaine noir est
rappelé en sciences po et bien il a
profité d'aidés coin et moi j'ai plein
beaucoup sur des critères territoriaux
sur des critères sociaux et territoriaux
il ya beaucoup de la science ça veut
dire que tu vois pas dit que ce qui est
derrière tout le voit pas ça ne s'est
pas passé au larzac est ok
sa tête est ce que oui d'accord mais on
joue à ce que pour amorcer la pompe pour
pour changer le regard ses terrasses et
pas une sorte de coup de pouce monde
moderne changent de regard plein les
projecteurs mettons-les là où il faut
les mettre
moi j'en ai marre du bac + 5 au chômage
dans le père était ouvrier
j'ai un garçon mais je vous ai parlé de
ce gala qui est le 4ème inventeur du
monde gt1 jour un colloque c'est pas des
exceptions je vous assure un colloque où
il y avait un gars un jeune maghrébin
qui disaient qu'ils étaient 12 dans leur
famille à neuf médecins spécialisés le
père était ouvrier spécialisé
c'est là qu'il faut qu'on met le
projecteur pas sur ce qui ne marche pas
je comprends pas pourquoi nous avons
cette schizophrénie de mettre le
projecteur là où ça ne marche pas
mettons le projecteur là où ça marche et
le petit derrière c'est à dire yes we
can
moi c'est ça que je veux que le gamin se
disent derrière je peux le devenir parce
que j'ai vu des modèles et si la télé a
peut-être du sens et par rapport à cela
c'est l'assemblée a du sens et avec avec
abriel simplement qu'ils sociable mais
qu'on ne dise pas que c'est la
discrétion positive que les parties
prennent leurs responsabilités qui se
dit ce n'est la musique depuis 50 ans
n'allons pas chercher le nul au km de
banlieue qui a décollé hier un élu alors
plaint le médecin qui me dit avec depuis
cinquante ans alors c'est pas si on
reviendra jamais il est impatient à
qualité égale est ce qu'il faut de temps
en temps encore aujourd'hui donner le
petit coup de pouce pour ce soit plutôt
le représentant des rues étaient noires
entre guillemets ou anwar en tout cas
qui prenne le poste pour montrer que ça
ait 10 où c'est possible
moi je suis très favorable à la
discrimination positive dont on peut
parler de l'affirmative action
tout ce que l'on veut mais je dis que
pour rétablir un prix leur mentor et la
parité
il faut un peu de discrimination
positive pendant un certain temps je
prends un cas bien précis qu'elle a la
chance
jeune guyanais j'aime bien des france de
rentrer à l'ena quand on sait que bon il
y a des milliers de parisiens qui vont
s'y présenter des milliers de blanc et
qu'il sera peut-être un centième au 1
1.000e communique rien déficit culturel
forcément parce qu'ils viennent d'un
déficit sur le lien en termes de en
termes de nombre déjà au départ et puis
économique aussi en termes de normes en
termes économiques comité faut des
bourses jungle guyanaise ne serait ce
que pour revenir après dans son pays
c'est pas évident pour lui c'est simple
les les hauts fonctionnaires en guyane
pour d autres maires commencé pour moi
tant on fait un peu la confusion entre
deux mers en queue et noir mais bon il
faut en parler quand même les
fonctionnaires doivent tous passés par
les grandes écoles administrative
il faut il pour y rentrer et il faut
passer des concours je trouve que c'est
important c'est que je repense quand
même à cette polémique est faite en
début d'année du magazine elle
ou ce magazine prétendait faire un
article soit la mode black la blatte la
chaîne jeudi à l'évidence dans une
rédaction où il y aurait eu des ddd
comment dire des journalistes noirs et
je pense que des gens se seraient
révoltés contre un article qui
expliquait et tranquillement tourner des
gens qui ne savent pas l'expliquer des
articles et de fêter tranquillement que
c'est noir qui autrefois était arrimé au
code du streetwear et du hip hop avait
miraculeusement découvert la mode à
l'arrivée des obama à la maison blanche
et tout l'article qui se voulait
sympathique à l'égard des noirs en
disant oh ces braves noir quand même
maintenant il sa famille et était
purement scandaleux c'était vraiment une
espèce de racisme condescendant et une
polémique qui a éclaté parce que des
gens dont moi audrey pulvar sonia
rolland etc ont réagi pour dire que
c'était intolérable mais dans une
rédaction avec des gens d'origines
diverses ça n'aurait pas eu lieu
et je pense que c'est aussi important
pour la qualité de l'information que des
gens avec des approches différentes des
regards différents puissent apporter
leur contribution à la perception qu'on
est ce qu'on peut avoir un gars un petit
peu optimiste sur cette évolution là
parce que gace toit est plus optimiste
que vous ne l'êtes sur le thème il met
en avance me gaston cette évolution
cette émergence au fil du temps parce
que les noirs comme tout le monde font
des études accède aux mêmes professions
que les blancs en fait c est que la pro
là la population se métisse à tous les
niveaux de responsabilité
est ce que c'est le temps qui va faire
l'histoire ici me suis exigeante
c'est je suis tout à fait consciente du
fait que même vous vous disiez il ya 5
il y à il ya dix ans je pense qu'il ya
cinq ans il ya cinq ans j'aurais pas été
à cette table a parlé de la question des
noirs
donc évidemment ça bouge je fais partie
d'une génération qui effectivement
accède au média la possibilité
d'exprimer de contredire parfois
certaines personnes de nos élites qui
répondent les préjugés donc évidemment
ça bouge apprennent à mon histoire à mon
amour je parle je parlais pas de voile
et eric zemmour et henri guaino se
reconnaîtront les mais non non non ce
que je veux dire c'est que malgré tout
on a on est pressé c'est à dire que moi
j'ai 34 ans on n'a pas envie d'attendre
une autre génération pour que les choses
arrivent
moi j'ai pas envie si demain j'ai des
enfants qu'on leur dise tu viens d'où
j'ai envie que mes enfants se
reconnaissent pleinement dans ce pays
comme étant des français à part entière
et c'est l'exemple typique quand il
avait commencé l'émission en disant
c'est un beau livre c'est lorsque vous
avez dit parce que c'est la réaction de
beaucoup de gens qui ont lu ce livre qui
m'ont dit c'est la première fois qu'on
fait un beau lit sur cette histoire
et ça commence aussi par ça ce qu'on est
en train de dire c'est le temps de dire
que vont aller cette histoire allait un
peu à côté
leur présence a l'air un peu à côté ils
vont quand même se contenter de ce
qu'ils ont non ils se contentent ils
sont mais ils sont totalement nos égaux
ils ont droit de choisir totalement leur
parcours c'était française mais il ya de
réel handicap aujourd'hui que mène la
société vous parlais tout à l'heure de
ce qui change en ce moment n'oublions
pas qu'on vient d'élire dans un parti
politique français à la tête de ce parti
politique quelqu'un qui est justement
éviter de trop mais celle aussi de
révolution ou pas les terres de
footballeur qui commence à prendre la
parole sur les questions d'anti racisme
c'est très très bien qu'ils ne se
contente pas simplement gagner de
l'argent parce qu'ils sont aussi des
modèles pas la nouvelle génération et
demain ce que vient de dire au kenya qui
va être fondamental c'est qui va
simplement falloir surveiller qu'on ne
valons pas régresser
l'inquiétude allait pas quoi on tend à
l'est que certains voudraient peut-être
fermer cette porte qui s'est ouvert
depuis dix quinze vingt ans et c'est là
on doit y arriver
est-ce que non juste un mot à mot c'est
l'appellation ont conclu est ce que pour
réussir le nord doit-il pas se franciser
à 100% je pense pas je pense pas parce
que si ça voulait dire ça faudrait tout
recommencer à zéro parce que là ça fait
4 5 d'histoire visite est complètement
et là il se rappelle votre appel
la france noire trois siècles de
présence très beau livre avec des très
belles photos d'illustrations qui nous
aide à comprendre d'où vous venez de
nous venons si je puis dire puisque
notre histoire est intimement lié voilà
merci merci à vous tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat merci à aurait
dit à face de l'avoir préparé je vous
rappelle notre adresse internet je vous
dis aussi que dans une semaine votre
vraie dominique souchier qui vous
parlera de pédophilie un sujet délicat
nous on se retrouve dans 15 jours et je
vous dis à bientôt bien sûr sur public
sénat